حسنًا ، هذا الصباح ، يعد اختراقًا طبيًا رائعًا
لرجل يمشي الآن أكثر
من عقد بعد تعرضه
لإصابة في الحبل الشوكي بالشلل
أصيب جانوسكوم البالغ من العمر 40 عامًا في حادث دراجة نارية منذ
أكثر من عقد من الزمان ، مما
منعه من اتخاذ خطوة واحدة
ولكن الآن الأطباء في  لقد
ساعدته سويسرا على استعادة قدرته على السير
في أفكاره
قبل عامين ، تواصلت مع
فريق من العلماء في سويسرا ،
وبعد ذلك تمكنت من المشاركة في تجربة إكلينيكية
لواجهة دماغية للعمود الفقري حيث وضعوا
غرسات في دماغي وفي دماغي.  العودة إلى
تعلم المشي مرة أخرى
مذهل ، إليك كيفية عمل الغرسات
في الدماغ لتتبع نوايا
الحركات ، صحيح أن ما يفكر فيه في
نقلها يتم نقله لاسلكيًا
إلى وحدة المعالجة التي يرتديها الشخص
خارجيًا مثل حقيبة الظهر التي رأيته
يرتديها هناك.  يقول إنه يمكنه الآن المشي
بطول ملعب كرة القدم
والوقوف دون استخدام ملعبه